una compañía de cable con una reputación
de servicio al cliente deficiente pierde
suscriptores a una tasa aproximada del
3% por año la compañía tenía 2 millones
de suscriptores al inicio del 2014 si
suponemos que la compañía sigue
perdiendo suscriptores a la misma tasa y
que no hay suscriptores nuevos en verdad
es una muy mala situación para ellos
cuál de las siguientes funciones se
modela el número de suscriptores
restantes en millones de años después
del inicio del 2014 vamos a pensar un
poco en este problema cuando t es igual
a cero
bueno s de cero es decir cero años
después del inicio del 2014 ese de cero
nos dice el número de suscriptores que
tiene la compañía al inicio del 2014 que
ya sabemos que son dos millones
así que ese tercero es igual a 2
recuerda es esta tarda en millones por
lo que s de 0 es igual a 2 ahora cuál es
el valor que toma ese cuando te es igual
a 1 es decir st1 bueno
un año después la compañía perdió el 3%
de sus suscriptores y perder el 3% es lo
mismo que retener el 97% entonces será 2
por 0.97
ahora qué pasará entre igualados después
de dos años bueno
empezaron con dos millones después de un
año fueron capaces de retener sólo el 97
por ciento y después de otro año la
compañía sólo será capaz de retener el
97 por ciento de lo que tenía el año
pasado por lo tanto multiplicaremos por
otro 97% y creo que podemos ver la
tendencia vamos a multiplicar por sí
mismo 97% tantas veces como te si nos
preguntamos por ese de 3 empezamos con
dos millones y después de un año se
retienen el 97% de ellos después de otro
año retienen el 97% de éstos así que
multiplicamos otra vez por 0.97 y
después de otro año entre igual a 3
retienen el nombre
y 7 por ciento de esto otro
en general sts da igual a la cantidad
con la que empezamos por 0.97 elevado a
la potencia t
sea cual sea la cantidad de años que
hayan pasado elevar así tu tasa de
retención a esa potencia y claro después
habrá que multiplicar por tu número
inicial de suscriptores y eso te dará a
los suscriptores que quedarán en ese
momento y veamos cuál de las opciones
tiene esta estructura bueno es esta
opción ahora otra forma de resolverlo es
intentar eliminar algunas opciones la
primera nos dice que la cantidad de
suscriptores está creciendo si
multiplicas por un 1.03 elevado a la t
bueno 1.03 por 1.03 por 1.03 esto es más
grande que uno por lo tanto tendrás más
de dos millones de suscriptores a medida
de que te aumenta entonces tenemos que
cancelar esta opción
en la tercera cada año se retiene solo
el 70 por ciento de los suscriptores
estamos perdiendo un 30% no un 3% de los
suscriptores por lo que esta es una
situación peor que la que tenemos y en
la cuarta opción tenemos una función
lineal es decir estamos multiplicando
por de una forma sencilla de ver que
esta ecuación no es correcta es pensar
que pasante igual a cero entre igual a
cero esto nos dará cero pero entre igual
a cero no tenemos cero suscriptores
entre igual a cero debemos tener dos
millones de suscriptores
otra forma de pensarlo es que esto va a
crecer mientras te crece cuando en
realidad debemos de crecer en el número
de suscriptores y es por eso que también
podemos cancelar esta opción